if you haven't done it in training you
will not do it in a race yeah it's
that's simple no you just got to put the
hours in and then it all comes together
on race day right right well you know
what it doesn't you know it doesn't
I'm gonna say that today's guest is the
world's most versatile professional
endurance athlete his name is Cam wurf
this is a guy who has distinguished
himself at the highest most elite level
in three distinct Sports first in rowing
where he represented Australia in the
2004 Athens Olympics but then he turns
his sights on professional cycling and
over the years becomes a Super Dome SD
team Skye and our team ineos he can set
bite course records at the world's most
prestigious Iron Mans and he can even
run a 245 marathon after a 2.4 mile swim
and a 112 mile bike an athlete can do
anything I don't really believe that he
can dream something that isn't possible